التكيف السليمانيه بدمشق ارث حضاري مهدد
بالضياع
[موسيقى]
على ضفاف نهر بردى وسط اقدم عاصمه ماهوله
في التاريخ تتربع منذ نحو خمسه قرون
التكيه السليمانيه لكنها اليوم يبدو انها
لن تبقى كما كانت حاضنه احد اعرق الاسواق
التراثيه في الشرق الاوسط
اخلاء وتخوف
[موسيقى]
هذا لسانه
اليدويه في التكيه السليمانيه بدمشق وهم
يخلون محل لهم بعد انذارهم من قبل حكومه
النظام بدعوه في منتصف اكتوبر 2022 اخترت
وزاره السياحه السوريه اصحاب المهن بانهاء
عقود استثمار المحال مع حلول عام
2023 من اجل استكمال مشروع اعاده تاهيل
الذكيه للحفاظ على المكان
اي من الهبوطات والتصدعات الانشائيه حسب
وصف نضال ماجفاج معاون وزير السياحه
السوري
تلميح حكومي بعدم العوده
[موسيقى]
شيوخ الكار من الحرفيين الذين يستاجر
معظمهم المحال منذ قرابه 50 عاما متخوفون
من اندثار عشرات المهن التراثيه وانقطاع
مصدر رزقهم ويخشون حرماهم من العوده الى
التكيه بعد انتهاء اعمال الترميم كحال
نظرائهم في سوق الزجاج المجاوره والتي ما
زالت حطاما حتى الان
سوريا اكد انه لا يوجد اي بند قانوني يلزم
الوزاره بتجديد عقود الحرفيين بعد
انتهائها كل سنه وانه رفقا للقانون يحق
للوزاره ان تطالب باخلاء المحال لاغراض
المصلحه العامه قبل انتهاء مده العقد ومن
دون ان يحق لاصحاب المحال المطالبه باي
عطل او ضرر
ترميم ام استثمار
في اب اغسطس 2019 دخلت جريده الوطن السوري
عن المدير العام لمديريه الاثار والمتاحف
التابعه للنظام محمود حمود ان التكيه
السليمانيه ايله للسقوط ويجب ان ترمم
وتستثمر واعلن عن مشروع لاعاده تاهيل
التكيه واستثمارها بانشاء مطعم في القاعه
المقابله لجامع التكيه الكبرى وقاعه اخرى
للماكولات السوريه موضحا ان المشروع لا
يهدف الى اخراج الحرفيين من محالهم
الاعلان اثار حينها مخاوف الحرفيين في سوق
المهن اليدويه
وراوا انه يعني اخراجهم من محالهم وعدم
اعادتهم اليها وابدا استعدادهم للمساهمه
في عمليه الترميم
اياد خفيه تحمل بصمات النظام
لكن ما يخشاه الحرفيون اصبح حقيقه فقد تم
بالفعل اغلاق 40 محلا لتبدا المرحله
الاولى بترميم جزء من التكيه وما يعرف
بسوق الزجاج وشع وقت اذن بين الحرفيين
وموظفي وزاره السياحه ان الترميم تقوم فيه
مؤسسه الامانه السوريه للتنميه التي
اسستها وتتراسها اسماء الاسد وانه سيكون
مشروع عن استثماريا خاصه بها يرجح ان
يستمر لتسعه وتسعين عاما
[موسيقى]
بديل غير ممثل
بحسب مصادر محليه تلقى اصحاب محل سوق
المهن اليدويه وعودا شفهيا بالعوده الى
محالهم حين الانتهاء من اعمال الترميم مع
امتناع وزاره السياحه عن توثيق ذلك كتابه
وهو ما زاد الشكوك لدى الحرفيين بامكانيه
العوده خاصه وان المكان الذي خصصته
الوزاره بديل لسوق المهن الاثريه وما تسمى
حاضنه دمر المركزيه للفنون الحرفيه والتي
انشاتها وزاره الصناعه في دمر البلد وهي
منطقه تبعد ثمانيه كلمترات عن مركز مدينه
دمشق في شمالها الغربي ولم يمضي على
انشائها اكثر من عامين ونصف العام
هندسه عثمانيه
[موسيقى]
التكيه السليمانيه الى السلطان العثماني
سليمان القانوني الذي امر المعماري الشهير
سنان ببنائها
1553 في موقع القصر الابلق لصاحبه السلطان
المملوكي الظاهر بيبرس واستغرق تشييدها
سته اعوام تبلغ المساحه الاجماليه للتكيه
نحو 11,000 متر مربع ويتالف بناؤها من
كتلتين معماريتين غربيه تضم الجامعه
والتكيه والشرقيه تضم المدرسه وتصل بينهما
سوق تتصف على جانبيها عشرات الحوانيت
التجاريه
تاريخيا كانت التكيه مكانا لاداء الفروض
الدينيه واستراحه للحجاج وملجا للمشردين
والفقراء ومنذ منتصف سبعينيات القرن
الماضي بدات احتضان عشرات محل الحرف
اليدويه الدمشقيه العريقه
هل تتحول حاضنه العراقيه الشاميه الى
مشروع ربحي
في كتابه العماره في الحضاره العربيه
الاسلاميه يصف عبد القادر الريحاوي التكيه
السليمانيه بانها مجموعه عمرانيه فخمه
تخلب الالباب بقبابها المنتظمه كالعقد حول
قبه رئيسيه كبيره تحيط بها مئذنتان
ممشوقتان
وتتخللها حدائق واشجار باسقه يمتزج جمالها
بمحاسن العماره فيجعل من هذه البقعه في
دمشق من اجمل البقع واكثرها جمالا
فهل ستعود التكيه السليمانيه كما كانت
عالما تراثيا وسياحيا يضم اهم صناعات
الحرفيه العريقه ويختزل الهويه الثقافيه
والاجتماعيه لدمشقين وكثير من السوريين ام
انها ستكون ضحيه المشاريع الربحيه بحكومه
النظام والمؤسسات التي تعمل في ظلها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]